bonjour le café politique en mode
estival au cours de la prochaine demi
heure nous allons revenir sur quelques
unes des séquences marquantes de cette
émission vous le savez les élus se sont
succédé ici au bistrot du théâtre à
montigny le bretonneux pour parler de
l'actualité bien évidemment mais aussi
de leur parcours et de leur engagement
dans la séquence qui va suivre c'est
joséphine coleman berger la mère de
plaisir et qui nous parle de sa
précédente vie de comédienne et de
metteur en scène elle qui a notamment
adapté au théâtre la bande dessinée les
bidochon
c'était comment cette videmment c'était
bien non non je la regrette pas non bien
sûr que non ça a été un choix de ma part
très très réfléchi parce que pendant un
certain temps que j'ai eu une
concomitance entre la vie politique en
tant qu'adjointe à la culture et ma vie
professionnelle effectivement de metteur
en scène de théâtre et un moment donné
il a fallu faire un choix et je les fais
mais sans aucun regret très bon vous
avez si les adaptations de bandes
dessinées notamment les bidochon par
exemple quels souvenirs vous gardez de
votre vie d'avant
justement je garde un souvenir
extraordinaire que j'ai fait des
rencontres particulièrement forte
ne serait-ce que tout le travail avec
fluide glacial avec monsieur binet qui
était le dessinateur débile de chant
avec qui j'ai travaillé sur l'adaptation
carmen cru également puisque a lieu plus
de 700 représentations sur les 220 que
ce soit les bidochon carmen cru alors je
peux pas dire je suis une spécialiste de
la bande dessinée mais en tout cas
pendant cette période où ils ont avec la
compagnie hong lei pied et on a fait
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
représentations qui sont en france ou en
europe et ça a été vraiment une vie
passionnante de tourner un petit peu ce
que les gens savent du théâtre et des
compagnies théâtrales qui fonctionne
bien on a eu cette chance de très très
bien fonctionné vous avez attrapé le
virus de la politique tout de suite vous
êtes dit faut que j'aille encore après
plus loin que la culture ça s'est pas
passé comme ça je m'en suis pas rendu
compte moi-même je crois qu'il ya eu des
choses qui ont été plutôt des évidences
vous savez quand on fait du théâtre ou
quand on est professeur monsieur j'ai
été professeur également dans une école
internationale sur la production de
spectacles vivants et bien vous donner
vous donnez vous êtes à l'écouté vous
êtes dans une proximité des très grandes
avec les gens et finalement c'était pas
une continuité mais presque
alors je voudrais pas vous entendre dire
que la politique et théâtre se sent
beaucoup mais je me voyais seulement
après l'agression avec ma maison c'est
dont souffrent les assises c'est un peu
vrai quand même si oui bien sûr regardé
la preuve est bien là je suis sous les
projecteurs ça ne change pas beaucoup
parce que j'étais comédienne aussi donc
on pourrait dire que je peux m'en servir
non c'est plutôt un atout supplémentaire
d'être à l'aise mais c'est surtout je
dirais cette volonté de s'occuper d'un
vrai projet et
remettre c'est un projet extraordinaire
parce que vous êtes en proximité des
gens et je pense avoir au moins cette
qualité là c'est d'aimer les gens je me
suis engagé en politique
j'étais dans mon salon je regarde à la
télé et puis je me rappelle plus très
bien ce que c'était mais j'avais vu un
reportage sur une situation en france et
je m'étais dit ça peut faut que ça
change
et pour changer les choses il faut avoir
le pouvoir et pour voir le pouvoir il
faut s'engager en politique il faut
militer
il faut aller voter et donc c'est ce que
j'ai fait je me suis engagé au sein de
l'ump parce que évidemment je fais des
valeurs de droite en l'autorité le
mérite le travail et donc voilà tout est
parti de là c'était clair dès le début
le choix de la famille ben oui oui et
c'était l'ump mais ses sermons ouais
vous aviez envie de faire carrière
politique déjà à cette époque
hélas aujourd'hui est ce que vous avez
envie de faire carrière dans la
politique j'avais déjà à l'époque
j'avais envie d'être ne mord pas parce
comme j'y suis né je suis natif de la
ville et donc je suis enraciné dans ma
ville
donc j'avais envie de porter des
justement des projets pour les mois
passent bien et d'améliorer de ma ville
donc voila c'était en tout cas
l'ambition que j'avais à l'époque et
aujourd'hui donc cette carrière
politique
là vous étiez remplaçant se plairont sur
les élections départementales donc en
cas de désistement des têtes de liste
vous prendrez la place au conseil
départemental
c'est comme ça que vous allez progresser
continuer en politique lors de chaque
jour longtemps je suis jeune mère ça
fait un an que je suis élu j'ai 32 ans
je ne suis pas comme beaucoup d'hommes
politiques ils sont déjà dans la presse
moi je suis dans le présent
j'agis maintenant et voilà j'ai tout
l'avenir devant moi la politique pour
vous débute à 19 ans vous êtes né en 67
engagement militant lors d'une
manifestation organisée contre le projet
de réforme de l'université de damas
vaquette le ministre de jacques chirac à
l'époque c'est ça le déclenchement de
l'engagement politique non vous ça
remonte à sa wii est bon en terme
d'engagement
les premiers la conscience politique je
pense que la confiance et la netiquette
tu es né avant tout cas la conscience
politique
quelque chose assez sommaire un peu
rudimentaire au départ mais quand on est
quand on a 16 17 ans mais j'étais très
heurtée par le racisme pas pourquoi
parce que j'ai fait une partie de ma
scolarité comme en font en afrique noire
et où on était là il ya moins d'écho
notre très mélangés par définition peu
d'européens et quand je suis rentré en
france et avait été très frappé par
partagés en bretagne n'était pas une
spécialement une région raciste mais il
y avait du racisme et c'est ça qui m'a
qui a été le moteur
mon engagement je
je portais assez mal les manifestations
d'intolérance en direction de jean juste
raison de leur couleur de peau et le
parti socialiste ça s'est imposée
justement dans cette rue
c'était parti de gauche qui étaient là
qui étaient disponibles vous savez ça
cesse joie des beaucoup de hasards de
hasard au sens où vous rencontrez des
personnels
moi j'ai pas été trotskiste la jeunesse
par exemple d'ailleurs le point lundi
qu'il était trop ce qui s'est bien une
chose que j'ai pas été trotskiste
ressentais pas une certaine frustration
parce que vous le dites vous êtes un
soutien du françois hollande d'avant le
changement s'est avancé plus maintenant
il n'ya pas une certaine frustration
d'incarner une ligne politique qui n'est
pas majoritaire aujourd'hui finalement
si on s'en tient au vote des différentes
motions et puis au congrès également non
parce que votre sont la politique c'est
un éternel rapport de force donc c'est
rien n'est jamais fini c'est au sein de
sa famille politique voire les et les
sujets
les uns après les autres il ya des
sujets sur lesquels on arrive à obtenir
gain de cause
il ya d'autres auront ce plus difficile
mais on est voilà c'est pas oui pour
répondre à votre question ou même dans
sa famille politique et randonnées
mais c'est vrai partout et on est on est
on est en permanence dans un équilibre à
trouver et
essayer de s'imposer par le débat par en
manière plus intelligente possible de
mes de s'imposer pour faire valoir ses
idées
qu'est ce qui a motivé cet engagement là
parce que vous l'avez dit ça a été
difficile au début il n'y avait pas
d'appuyer vous n'étiez pas au sein d'une
majorité pour apprendre justement il a
fallu apprendre tout seul un petit peu
mais parce que l'on précédé parcours de
vivre j'ai fait mes études j'ai commencé
à enseigner puis abandonnée c'était plus
suffisant il fallait que j'aie jamais
besoin de cet engagement militant depuis
très longtemps et puis le constat aussi
de d'un certain manger bien de ma
famille ancrée à gauche syndicalistes
mais l'engagement politique c'est un
autre un autre pas et c'est aussi le
fruit aussi deux gouttes de constats
concernant les injustices ou dès qu'ils
font car en donner aux finances c'est
pas possible il faut s'engager et puis
aussi le constat parfois de devoir le
personnel politique qui est en
responsabilité on dit bah finalement je
te donnerai pas de noms mais on vibre
pas forcément plus mal quoi que ce soit
à gauche ou à droite
oui ça l'arlequin ce qui est plutôt à
droite mais aujourd'hui par exemple mais
je pense qu'il sait ce qu'il faut dire
aussi à tous ceux qui hésitent à
s'engager sur que c'est pas un métier de
faire la politique c'est des convictions
et donc tout fait moi je l'appelle à
tout ce qui est qui parfois râle sont
pas contents à venir rencontrer à
s'engager en politique et
à montrer qu'ils peuvent peut-être faire
mieux qu'est ce qui vous a poussé vers
l'ump vers la droite vers l'est
républicain aujourd'hui est ce qui vous
a poussé à l'origine j'ai toujours été
gaulliste
par tradition à la fois familial et puis
l'itinéraire que j'ai suivie depuis mon
adolescence
ma première affiche les coller en 65
donc vous voyez que c'est pas séparés
sans même si c'était dans quel cadre
c'était à l'époque pour la campagne
présidentielle du général de gaulle
d'une affiche extraordinaire que j'avais
qui malheureusement disent pas ce que je
vais vous demander vous n'avez pas gardé
je l'avais gardé trocadéro et lors d'un
déménagement
on voyait une main un bras avec deux
étoiles qui tenait marianne c'était le
grand dessinateur savignac qu'il l'avait
fait et c'est écrit dessus j'ai c'est
pas en laissez moi grandir elle était
magnifique stuff
vous avez été à députés on l'a mentionné
brièvement aussi mais poste de
secrétaire d'état de ministres ça par
contre ça ne figure pas dans votre cv
est ce que c'est des regrets alors
comment vous l'expliquer parce que il ya
des choses qui se disent s'il y avait
des hommes forts sur le département des
yvelines et quelques années vous en
faisiez partie avec également michel
rocard et vous n'avez pas forcément
d'affinités avec lui et sait que c'est
fini que c'est lui qui n'avait pas
d'affinités avec vous mais je crois
parce que ça venait pas de lui alors
c'est le cas c'est ce qui explique la
tension autour de la politique
politicienne et c'est en tout cas
j'étais le responsable du crs au parti
socialiste dans le département enfin
avec d'autres me dire voilà
et puis et puis michel surtout des amis
à lui était responsable du courant roc a
un peu le même schéma qu'aujourd'hui on
a une bouche à gauche et une gauche plus
à droite utilise avec ont pu faire
et voilà et puis on s'entendait pas bien
et est donc je peux le raconter j'ai été
une fois il faut à proposer ministre du
logement et une tranquille victoire
c'était réglé c'était non parce que
parce que voilà maintenant il est un peu
têtu dit des choses qu'il faut pas dire
mais peut-être que leurs aînés et c'est
louis besson qui a été nommé ministre
est pour moi
non je n'ai pas de regrets on n'était
pas trop lésés position voilà face on
lui a fait un boulot formidable
et moi j'ai travaillé avec lui sur
plusieurs lois qui dure encore michel
rocard un homme qui a été influent pour
vous vous avez été président fondateur
du mouvement des jeunes socialistes
et c'est michel rocard qui a donné un
petit peu dépendance l'autonomie à à 7 à
cette formation
c'est surprenant michel rocard c'est
plutôt le libéral à la cause de la
gauche non mais c'est vrai palace non
mais c'est pas ça c'est gros qu'un c'est
plus et on classeront plaire
grossièrement canton du psi lui
mitterrand la bouche à oreille et rocard
la droite la réalité c'est que quand
vous regardez et vous le coup quand on
lit qu'entre prendre le temps de lire
michel rocard on vote par exemple dans
la critique qu'il a de la
financiarisation de l'économie
développant une forme de capitalisme
dévoyé et c'est qu'ils se désintéressent
finalement de l'outil industriel pause
se préoccuper que de la rentabilité de
l'action et du capital
il a eu un discours très fort et des
propositions qui ont été très
importantes et quand on voit la place
qu'il a accordé lui à la question par
exemple climatique il a un des premiers
socialistes s'est emparé de cette
question là où honnêtement on a été nous
ma gauche très en retard de ce qui était
les prises de conscience dans la société
civile ou du côté d'europe écologie les
verts par exemple de l'importance
aujourd'hui de du climat et de
l'environnement et pourquoi est ce que
c'est important d'ailleurs parce que
quand l'environnement se dégrade sa
touche au qui en premier les catégories
les plus vulnérables et les plus
modestes
et pour ça que l'enjeu environnemental
c'est aussi un enjeu social et des
associations la rocard oui ça a été une
ça reste une référence mais pour la
bouche même pour ceux qui ont fait cette
erreur politique
je n'ai pas revu depuis longtemps vont
être très honnête il leur croix de
l'année dernière et ça reste une
référence
intellectuel que je respecte avec
laquelle je conserve des points d'accord
évidemment vous disiez aussi tout à
l'heure avoir un moment où on fait un
petit peu marche arrière parce que vous
aviez d engagement personnel familial
puis des engagements professionnels
aussi parce que vous êtes dentiste au
civil voilà vous continuez votre
activité
4 5h pinceau bel hidalgo courez vous le
regrettez ou maintenant souhaite vous
êtes non reconverti en politique non
juba ont converti en politique voulait
garder cet hymne que je ne fais pas de
politique je gère une ville c'est pas
des gens qui se lancent en politique
pour faire une carrière et qui ont
presque un plan de carrière sais pas si
vous avez vu mais j'ai pas été candidat
aux cantonales alors que j'aurais pu
tout à fait ayant déjà été élu et réélu
j'aurais pu tout à fait me porter
candidat et il te pense que j'aurais été
mais je n'ai pas voulu le faire parce
que ce qui vous intéresse et l'amoureux
la gestion de ma ville je ne suis pas
allé non pas que le fait d'être
conseiller départemental ne sais pas un
mandat intéressant mais le fait de
m'occuper de la ville ainsi que somme
suffit vous êtes aussi vice président de
la communauté de versailles grand parc
vous avez tout de même été candidat en
tant que suppléant de jean michel
fourgous aux législatives sur la 11e
circonscription
il n'y a pas de volonté de justement
vous tourner un peu vers le national en
poste de député savoir territoire à mon
âge mon âge mon nom et vous pourriez
continuer longtemps candidats déjà pour
un autre mandat dans votre tête vous
vous dites ce mandat là ce sera ce sera
bien déjà j'ai dit que ce serait le
dernier
c'est clair et sac tu es mauvais mais
mandat municipal ont jusqu'à un âge
après faut pour passer à autre chose
vous êtes convaincus de la totale
déliquescence des fondements et des
valeurs mêmes de la république 1
absolument je suis gaulliste je me suis
d'ailleurs engagé en politique en 1958
avec le retour du
le bol en 1959 j'étais le plus jeune en
cartes et une v ner miss elles devraient
le premier ministre avait pris sous sa
tutelle
il m'a présenté au général c'était un
grand bonheur pour moi à l'époque je
n'ai jamais revu après de pas et de loin
oui mais de prénom mais ceci étant dis
donc je suis resté un gaulliste toute ma
vie et je continue donc à essayer tant
que faire se peut dans un monde
effectivement que je ne comprends plus
la france je ne comprends plus ce qui
s'y passe il ya plus d'éthique il ya
plus de morale l'intérêt général prend
le pas largement sur l'intérêt
particulier pardon sur l'intérêt général
et donc j'ai décidé que je ne pouvais
pas continuer à servir de caution
un système auquel je ne comprends plus
rien du tout vous avez 75 ans 30 ans la
tête une même commune 14 ans au conseil
général des yvelines dont 4 à la
vice-présidence également et pourtant
rien vraiment vous destiné à la
politique vous est tout sauf carriériste
non rien du tout non j'ai été on va lire
un molière
nelly temps extrêmement actif de 1958 à
1983 ou fils du maire c'était mon
premier mandat
donc je ne faisais que keita mais à mi
temps par toucher les mains jamais
vraiment extrêmement actifs sains et
puis c'est en 83 donc mon prédécesseur
et bien m'a appelé dans son équipe
municipale ou plutôt c'est moi
d'ailleurs qui signe le convaincre de
partir parce qu'il ne voulait pas
repartir aux municipales 83 on a gagné
il m'a nommé adjoint et en 86 il a
décidé de partir et il a dit qu'il va
demander de le remplacer je n'y étais
pas du tout préparés parce que j'avais
vue professionnel dans le nucléaire je
dirais extrêmement prenante et rien qui
vous destiné à la politique si ce n'est
le caractère peut être celui que vous
avez hérité de votre grand mère bretonne
vous avez récemment est tout à fait vous
avez récemment publié un livre la force
de la conviction aux éditions de
l'archipel et vous en parlait beaucoup
de votre grand mère elle vous a enseigné
et je vous cite l intégrité la publicité
la volonté de tracer votre route en
dehors des clous à la nage en portant
c'était une grand mère je dirais très
particulier il valait mieux ne pas la
croisée parce que il risque de vous
arriver
des procès fait virer immédiatement non
elle était vraiment extrêmement
volontariste et puis bon c'était était
son seul petit fils au départ entre
lakers unis après j'ai eu dix heures et
elle m'avait pris elle alors ce sont
elles me protégeait de mon père parce
que mon père lui était un coup de bâton
que ça se passait en permanence donc
effectivement ma grand mère m'a beaucoup
aidé et qu'il irait dans ma vie et après
tout peut-être que je tiens un peu de
son caractère ça va changer votre
caractère notre détermination vos
convictions absolument samedi sur
williams parce que j'étais un chèque à
pont l'abbé jules henri paillet très
mauvaise élève indiscipliné aussi ce
sont des défauts qu'on n'attend pas trop
pour un homme politique pourtant bah oui
mais ces lieux
je vous ai amené à présent sur un autre
terrain qui va pas forcément vous plaire
vous êtes une femme est ce que ça change
des choses en politique lorsqu'on était
à la tête d'une des plus importantes
communes des yvelines c'est la septième
7e commune des yvelines avec un peu plus
de 30000 habitants une des rares femmes
aussi présidente d'agglomération de
communautés de communes ça change
quelque chose c'est ce que c'est plus
difficile en politique est ce que vous
avez perçu les choses comme plus dur il
y avait plus de preuves à faire et je ne
sens pas et où alors je n'y pense pas
après deux tours parce qu'on vous le dit
on me dit par exemple est vous vous êtes
conscient que vous vous tenez une ville
de cette importance madame le maire j ai
ce que vous posiez cette question un
homme ça oui on me l'a dit plusieurs
fois je pense qu'il ya encore cette
surprise qu'on puisse avoir des
responsabilités de cette envergure je
vous avoue que au quotidien moi j'y
pense pas du tout j'aborde le monde
politique
énormément donne parce que dans des
grandes réunions vous voyez surtout
beaucoup d'hommes il ya très peu de
femmes encore mais je je me sens ni
différentes ni supérieur ni inférieure
je me sens tout à fait dans une
dynamique de travail et c'est ça qui
m'intéresse
vous n'êtes pas seule femme à diriger
une fédération socialiste en ile de
france
comment ça s'explique le parti
socialiste a du mal à se féminiser un
peu la vie politique en général et pas
facile pour les femmes même s'il ya eu
beaucoup de faits et je prends je pense
que si la gauche avait pas été au
pouvoir on n'en serait pas là puisque
toutes les doigts de parité toutes les
lois qui permettait plus de
représentativité des femmes se sont à
chaque fois des gouvernements de gauche
qui les ont portés mais c'est un travail
sur le long terme
et puis c'est vrai que on essaye de
changer mais les réunions politiques
c'est le soir donc pour une vie
familiale c'est compliqué comment vous
êtes accueilli par vos homologues hommes
masculin giresse jamais un enjeu mais
ressentie devant elles prennent par le
passé aujourd'hui peut-être monde
parlait pas sinon je ne veux pas jamais
ressenti de problème de ce côté-là
après c'est plutôt par fois que moi et
je me sens le dis que ça mais
comment vous avez réagi dans l'actualité
récente au niveau national à la
démission de yacine shawa on va préciser
un petit peu ce dossier c'était le
nouveau phare éphémère secrétaire
national adjoint du ps en charge de
l'intégration qui a été condamné par le
passé pour des violences conjugales qui
a été nommé tollé sur notamment les
réseaux sociaux
il a démissionné ils ont joué leur rôle
donc vous avez tout à fait puisque l'on
a abandonné
au moins on peut critiquer les réseaux
sociaux mais ça joue ce rôle d' alerte
aussi il ya plusieurs choses il ya une
première faute politique qui est l avoir
à nous mais je pense que ce soit de
votre ville politique ça on peut se
tromper c'est pas et ensuite il ya une
deuxième faute qui est la manière dont
lui s'est justifié pour démissionner est
ce qu'on se donnait ce jamais ce dossier
ne doit exister parce qu'il ne doit pas
être présent moi je suis pas pour qu'on
condamne les gens de 3 à 4 fois une fois
que les peines ont été
mais avant il ya aussi des postes à
responsabilités qui sont les postes
aussi on est exposé et je pense qu'on
pouvait trouver pleins pleins d'autres
personnes aussi capables que lui
d'assumer cette charge
c'était une erreur de proposer ce
best-of du café politique se poursuit il
est à présent question de
l'élargissement de l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines au 1er janvier
2016 les communes de maurepas de
coignières ou encore des
clayes-sous-bois avons intégré
l'ancienne ville nouvelle les maires
concernés ne contrera faire de la
figuration et ils le font régulièrement
elle savoir notamment sur notre antenne
et puis juste après un retour sur l'une
des polémiques de cette année à la
baisse des subventions à la culture par
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines justement la droite majoritaire
dit qu'il faut faire des économies la
gauche dans l'opposition s'insurge
1er janvier 2016 la ville de maurepas
ainsi que plaisir les claies ville
propre coignières rejoignent saint
quentin en yvelines pour faire une
agglomération de 230 mille habitants
c'est une bonne chose
c'est positif pour nos repas où il s'est
posé on a fait pas partie par le passé
de cet agglomérat tafer et 30 ans après
on y retournons d'envoyer le tanga nous
permettant des gains de temps je pense
que c'est une perte de temps parce qu'on
le voit avec les villes qui en font
partie
qui ont su se dynamise et notamment dans
leur zone d'activité économique dans la
rénovation de leurs équipements moi je
récupère des équipements qu'ils ont dans
un état lamentable et dans les villes
aux alentours qui font partie de la
caisse qui ils ont été financés grâce à
la communauté d'agglomération de saint
quentin
donc je pense que c'est c'est positif
pour la ville parce que nous sommes dans
un même bassin de vie et nous avons
beaucoup de choses en commun avec les
villans 30 notamment avec plaisir avec
les clés et villepreux et coignières
nous avons des projets communs qu'il
faudra porter ensemble au sein d'un
comité agglomération de saint quentin
comme d'ailleurs l'équipement nautique
puisque
plaisir et les clés et villepreux et
dans leurs communes d'agglomération une
piscine en commun donc je pense qu'il
faut qu'on apporte aussi ses sujets
l'ensemble mais malgré tout
l'agglomération de saint quentin qui est
à l'heure des choix il faut faire des
choix tout simplement pour faire des
économies il faut faire des choix sur
les compétences il fallait supprimer
certaines compétences se serait lesquels
vous qui allait arriver au sein de
l'agglomération 1 pour le moment on
n'est pas là mais j'imagine déjà oui car
derrière il ya des compétences
obligatoires et les compétences
optionnelles
il faudra discuter de tout ça il faudra
discuter du pacte financier également il
faut que ce soit gagnant-gagnant
moi je refuse que les impôts locaux
augmentent il faut baisser drastiquement
la dépense publique et il faut surtout
surtout est ce assez d'échecs des
intercommunalités
depuis des années c'est la mutualisation
de nos services si on j'entre dans une
grande communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
il faut qu'en mutualisant nos services
pour faire des économies et améliorer le
service public je souhaite pas rentrer
ou partir à la casse qui ont au moins
être avec la castille uniquement comme
ça sans réflexion il ya tout un travail
de préparation acer la casse qui a plus
de 30 ans d'existence
nous nous sommes une intercommunalité
tout petit mais malgré tout représentant
62 mille personnes ce n'est pas anodin
avec maurepas et coignières parce que je
continue de le dire eh bien nous
pourrions effectivement remettre à plat
les choses et avoir une réflexion en
commun pour que nous ne soyons pas
perdant dans cette opération
la défense de la culture à saint quentin
en yvelines
il ya eu des choix qui ont été faits par
ce qu'il faut faire des économies là
encore sur l'agglomération de saint
quentin il ya eu des combats budgétaire
sur l'aspect culture on va re préciser
que c'est pas une compétence obligatoire
non plus de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines qui a décidé de
faire des économies sur ses différents
postes et un collectif qui c'est qui
s'est monté avec beaucoup d'élus de
gauche voire tous les élus de gauche du
territoire pour défendre cette culture
ça c'est une valeur de mozilla défend je
vais emprunter à une chronique ce matin
de françois morel sur france inter
pendant cité une radio concurrente mais
cité churchill et je trouve que je me
marre ap cette citation que je
connaissais mais j'avais oublié turquie
et laquelle on disait demandé de couper
dans le budget de la culture pour
financer l'effort de guerre
il a répondu quoi mais alors pourquoi
nous battons nous il avait réclamé du
sang et des larmes
il avait elle annoncé qu'il aurait du
sang et des larmes au britannique mais
il a au moment on lui demande de couper
le budget de la culture pour financer
l'effort de guerre cette phrase-là ya
aujourd'hui à saint quentin la merise
grenier à sel ferme de bellevue le
scarabée tous ces équipements toutes ces
associations se voit privé de dizaines
de milliers d'euros un tiers de leurs
subventions parce que l'agglomération
fait le choix de couper dans ses
dépenses là est devenu aussi aux
communes de venir compenser oui comme
une vielle inverse à celle des
compétences des communes
mais sauf qu'on maintient heureusement
pour la scène nationale parce que c'est
une compétence de tiaré pour le prisme
elle encourt donc montigny elancourt
pour les moyens préserver je m'en
réjouis mais là où une question statue
sur les anciens soyez d'accord qui doit
aussi je vienne me dire par mai
ce que jusqu'à la fin on a des
engagements pris pour les saisons à
venir
à la merise
à la ferme de bel ébat quand comment on
fait on dénonce les contrats n'ont
évidemment on va pas le faire donc on a
été chercher des moyens supplémentaires
et on va les trouver
sans doute pour compenser cela mais
c'est un choix politique
cette attitude qui consiste de la part
de de l'agglo va passer le ballon de
rugby à d'autres en disant c'est pas ma
faute c'est l'autre mon la réalité c'est
que on a eu lieu avec les événements du
début de l'année les grandes
manifestations pour la république un
désir profond de se réunir de vivre
ensemble et justement quand est-ce qu'on
se retrouve sinon par la culture ou d'un
des territoires les plus créatifs les
plus innovants qui soit sur le plan
culturel on est en train de sacrifier
cela est bien ça va avoir un impact ça
va avoir des conséquences savoir y
compris des conséquences dans quantum de
vivre ensemble dans l'agressivité dans
le jeu
des personnes c'est évident c'est le
choix politiques faits par la majorité
de droite aujourd'hui d'agglomération je
le regrette
nous le combattrons et ne seront aux
côtés des acteurs culturels pour éviter
cette casse parce que je sais une
véritable casse de des équipements
culturels et des associations
culturelles sur le territoire les
conflits en politique ce n'est pas
réservé uniquement aux adversaires au
sein même des partis les tensions
existent dans la séquence qui va suivre
le maire de maurepas revient sur les
municipales et sur le fait qu'il n'ait
pas trouvé un soutien est total pendant
la dernière campagne et puis juste après
ce sera au tour du maire de coignières
de revenir sur l'épisode qui lui a coûté
le poste de conseiller départemental il
ya quelques années quand vous avez
décidé de vous lancer avec cette
légitimité de mort patients en quête du
poste de maire de la ville ça n'a pas
été si facile que ça sur votre route il
y avait pierre leguérinel il était
adjoint de georges mougeot le maire
divers gauche qui était en poste depuis
89 qui a décidé lui de ne pas se
représenter aux derniers scrutins
pire le guérinel qui quittent quelques
mois avant le scrutin la majorité et qui
veut porter une liste ump udi
et là vous famille politique se divise
vous l'avez vécu comment cette période
c'était une période compliquée parce que
c'est vrai que vous l'avez vous l'avez
rappelé les zigzags
de l'ancien premier adjoint de georges
mougeot et évidemment je croyais j'avais
la vérité avec moi et je croyais en ce
que je faisais à l'époque et évidemment
je crois que l'amour pages m'ont donné
les raisons de toute façon puisque ils
ont tranché ils ont tranché pour le
candidat du renouveau
celui avec son équipe qui fait de la
politique avec avec le choeur avec
sincérité avec honnêteté et voilà on
m'attend c'est du passé
mais la campagne a été difficile malgré
tout parce que ça laisse des traces
parce que au sein même de sa les
oliviers actionnaires et financer mon
investiture au tout début
l'ump qui revenu vers vous après pendant
l'entre-deux absolument vous a proposé
de faire une fusion avec pierre
leguérinel vous n'en avez pas voulu vous
êtes resté avec votre liste que vous
alliez composer j'étais persuadé que je
gagnerais sans alliance parce que
j'étais persuadé que pire le guérinel
partir et à gauche comme il l'avait fait
en 2008 au second tour et voilà les
résultats sont là ça a été une campagne
difficile alors je ne suis pas rancunier
par nature mais je n'oublie pas un
dernier mot on va parler et on en a
assez peu parlé à tout de même de votre
passage au conseil général vous en avez
été vice-président 2008
ça s'arrête en raison d'une division des
voix à droite dissidente à la vôtre une
liste menée par le premier adjoint
d'elancourt appuyé par le maire
d'elancourt maire d'elancourt qui
d'ailleurs vient de cette fois ci d'être
élu conseiller départemental en mars
dernier est un peu l'ironie de
l'histoire on n'est jamais trahi que
dans son propre camp oui absolument
c'est une histoire extrêmement
douloureuse j'étais vice président
sortant du conseil général
j'avais fait basculer en 94 alors que je
ne le cherchez pas je pensais que
j'allais être battu et je le souhaitais
pas ce même d'être battu et quand elle
peut de temps que j'avais pour la
première fois j'avais fait basculer le
canton de maurepas donc à droite et là
dessus je suis réélu en 2001 déjà avec
des bâtons dans les roues de grand
michel fourgous et en 2008 alors je suis
vice président sortant eh bien ils
décident de
présenté son premier engagement en
dissidence j'ai fait appel bien
évidemment alors au niveau départemental
et j'avais été investi par 481 voix 104
d'ailleurs michel jean michel fourgous
qui n'auraient son investiture sur elle
en cours dans la haute tenue de 350 355
et bien il a donc lancé son premier
adjoint en dissidence contre moi j'ai
fait appel au national jean michel
fourgous a été condamné
et on lui a demandé de retirer sa
dissidence il ne l'a pas fait et le rêve
de chaque 2e tour il y avait jean michel
favier et moi-même bon travail fait
virer les mois se divise et puis on perd
et donc his mind ivan donc et qui
représenteraient parti socialiste a
remporté le fasse un des épisodes les
plus douloureux de votre vie politique
je dirais que oui c'était assez
désastreux on a perdu le canton
et puis là dessus je n'ai pas accepté la
version était en procès tout ça et puis
il a été et il a perdu jean michel
fourgous le café politique se referme
c'est la fin de ce best-of l'intégralité
des émissions sont à retrouver sur notre
site internet ainsi que le premier
best-of consacrée aux premiers mois de
la saison je vous souhaite un très bel
été